The Comedy Store would like you to know
that the views and opinions expressed on
this podcast are strictly those of the
speakers or authors and do not
necessarily reflect or represent the
views and opinions held by the Comedy
Store and its affiliates
I've heard like vague things with him
like I was told for a long time I was
like mostly Scottish and then it won't
point my there's like thing not like
just it then it's like there's other
things again you are [ __ ] you can go
your scout I could see that I have a you
know I've objectively huge eyebrows yes
and I like that imagine everybody
together if I don't tend them everything
me yeah if I can harness their growth
like the power of their the speed of
their growth find the DNA will cure
baldness yeah no [ __ ] [ __ ] they are they
have to trim them with scissors Wow yeah
they're aggressive sexy I could have
those weird old man i browsed it without
a month couple of ago yes of a coated I
worked for a director that had weirdly
long eyebrows like that he wasn't super
old but I was just like how do you not
notice that every day yeah like just
[ __ ] cut him dude gotta look in the
mirror you can't if you feel it like my
eyelashes you look down drives me crazy
the reason I wear mascara oh really yeah
otherwise the rape my eyes oh weird I
don't trim my eyebrows every time I get
my hair cut the ladies like I don't know
you is a little bit like what oh yeah go
ahead then we're sorry about growing old
as a dude is ear hair yeah we're just
like hold on I'll be right out I'm
trimming my ear yeah yeah I don't let my
god i want to look like john wooden
before he died he had about 40 square
inches of lobe yeah every inch of it
yeah yeah where's your goddamn pyramid
of success for that ear sir you're
failing that is hilarious just let it
grow like a sideburn yeah me out I feel
a girl sideburns to me I could just do
it out I could i was able to grow
sideburns when I was like 17 it was the
only interesting thing about God ich7
he's Scottish this is [ __ ] i just sent
over here with my Welsh English Swedish
boy when you trying to get to four so i
can anger Kevin widest you know is i
miss the ax you may be a Welshman mr.
classic client he used to do a Jeff
Foxworthy style way
as you know you may be a Welshman yeah
listen I I don't know why I'm not
successful hi shovel you like is if you
ever found yourself with the Sheep of
ill repute you people well that is
awesome listen taken I I tried to take
everything all the way to the top and
just Rick and I once went on stage is a
rap duo yeah I was my hype man i just
stood behind him and said like word at
open mic are here yours or hear it fall
out or something was like a month no it
was it was a regular it was a Monday or
Sunday were and it was like you know one
am I was last there was no one there
knows like do you want just go up as a
rap duo and i'll be your hype man you
were like word it was when you were
calling yourself DJ pubes yeah and you
would just go again you're a good eres
your pubes dog whose dog straight oh
that's trait of pubes I don't want to
bring this back like you lose the
because of Darnell's yeah I was on I was
doing so many drugs like I literally
never would have thought of any of this
I cannot mention it tonight I was like
holy [ __ ] I did used to do that yeah
pubes don't you hate when people are
sober I won't ever everything I really
thought pubes can catch on it's like a
stray didn't stick to it that long I
remember you saying it like there's a
male voice on state yeah oh q yo cute I
think you should open with this sound so
much potential meaning behind yeah yeah
it's one of those catch shells yeah yeah
that was doing that just real free time
at this trust you no one was in charge
on any well it's still somewhat like
that but late night I mean yeah late
night because people just tend to tag
out late night but I think what you guys
what you're talking about is when it was
all night even prime time friday it was
like 30 people yet tops yeah you know I
was I'm here Brogan wasn't here right I
annex I believe that on a Friday and
Saturday you'd have tops 20 people neo
are yeah I mean there was no main room
show that's how yeah we were down to our
members to
saturdays and then upset like the manor
saturday be like the front section yes i
was never there for I didn't know the
curtains I used to schedule three
waitresses in the main room awful that
is I think there's eight in there
tonight yeah well I was thinking about
this on the way here the first benchmark
of me getting better at the store was
you telling me I got funnier like you
were oddly in charge yeah back then not
for sure sure currently oddly yeah you
got me my job I well yeah I did she you
were the one everyone listen to lay down
the law oh really she came up to me she
said so Steve Rannazzisi said you want
to work here it's like yeah that'd be
great she's like what's your name was
like but I was a nova micra then I went
by dick Ingram no you did yeah and she
goes what's yours am i rich to go a
[ __ ] room she guess it's not really
your name that's like my stage same
thing we're not calling you that nobody
here we're not calling you that I was
hired as Rick Ingram and that's the way
it's stuck yeah was it Rick that you
were hired us I think I mean maybe Kevin
remembers who i was hired as cuz i don't
know what character i was living in at
that oh no I'm talk about what I used to
call you the shermanator yeah that was
inator wasn't really a year probably
it's a whole year cuz I thought it was
like right away I was like oh my just
the allows after I started talking to
dice and now I he didn't talk to me for
a couple years probably the first
interaction I had with dice was him
yelling at makes I parked in his spot
ooh and here's his spot it's dick
exactly he doesn't have a speedo i'm
like 'i just decided to yell at a
defenseless lamb really did it was like
as you the [ __ ] car like that and
Bobby Lee classic Bobby codependent like
yeah a lap dog who just gets close to
whoever is the biggest bully just stands
live
ah like that straight to the slaughter I
was just like catty sháá really
slaughter him sorry this phone yeah it
was such an odd time but you were oddly
the most in charge yeah so I like God
offstage having like one of my first
three decent sets you just went you're
getting funnier sci-fi and I was like
really boys crack yeah you were a layer
but wait okay what this is the comedy
store podcast yeah forgot to introduce
that's the best I really like rock this
[ __ ] is still punk we are Kevin Christy
with us today you say your name and like
what nationality you are name is Kevin
Kristen least favorite nerd Scottish
third Irish third German all right so
let's get to the third boring but wait
what okay so what year did you come here
cuz I don't gather room I think it must
have been like two thousand one or two
thousand to somewhere that idea yeah I
came in 2002 and you were on the friends
and family yeah I wasn't passed I got on
the friends and family well back then it
was just called employee list yeah right
and I got on that quick just cuz Bobby
vouch for me because we had done an ampm
commercial together so you're you're
another Bobby brought in cuz yes I what
people say but I was a Bobby bringing
cuz we did a commercial together and
then I ran into him like a year later at
a record store was like I want and I had
gone to see him right after we did the
commercial I came around a Thursday Neef
and you know and for some reason it was
packed and he [ __ ] lift the room on
fire and I was like oh [ __ ] this place
is crazy and so like a year later I saw
him at amoeba and I was like hey I think
I want to be a comedian and he was like
okay come meet with me at the coffee
bean on sunset and I like the next day
or something and I was like here my
jokes and he goes to jokes don't matter
come on Sunday Monday come on Sunday
Monday I'll get you three minutes and I
was like oh maybe I should wait and he
goes if you don't show up I'll never
help you again so i just showed up and
he'd like walked up to re s like this is
my friend he's funny put him on so he
put me on and then I just kept coming
back and not bothering re i would show
up I'd say hey I'm here and I'd go sit
in the back and I wouldn't say a [ __ ]
word and everyone would bother him yeah
i mean just pepper him
non-stop you got classf I guess what so
if if he had an extra spot he would give
it to me and it just I ended up I mean I
had a way easier time getting in here I
never did the open mic I was basically
on the employee list right away I never
did that's all I remember about you was
at first just like man I wonder how this
guy got in is that you incur talk for
the two guys on the Employee List that
weren't employee Yeah Yeah right well
that was because he's polish polish
friend I just didn't understand how am I
don't even know that I was on the list i
just would get put up a great that's
what I mean yeah it was like you just
was like a thing if Kirk came in or does
it just put them up i only own only show
up open mic night which then was Sunday
Monday Tuesday yeah and uh it was I
wanted to they're talking about tuesday
they on that fought about I couldn't get
in the other nights cuz I didn't have
enough money to pay for tickets yeah I
wouldn't let you just sit in the back
back then really so does the only night
I was here so you were like one of the
only comics that I'd ever see go up yeah
cuz I'd always leave by the time the
paid regulars were well I my strategy
was I didn't I never like took it for
granted so I would show up like when it
started I would show up early and wait
the whole entire time and if I didn't
get a spot I didn't even say anything I
wouldn't be like hey next time maybe I
would just leave and ari was the only
open mic host really back then sorry and
Skippy oh yes you can be skipping to the
two and I when I was around however
watching tonight remember getting the
most complaints as a waitress I'm just
saying the same how strange there was
some awful mo god damn it from the staff
from white tile that I'm the worst thing
that ever had that's the worst thing
I've ever seen happen on the stage was
white Kyle really sit down you blender
he goes hey what's up black [ __ ] to a
woman who was just sitting there out of
like 10 people doing 10 people in the
crowd five of them were this lovely
black family and this idiot of a dumb
[ __ ] goes up and goes what's up black
[ __ ] and I've never heard a silence
like that and I'm hope I was hosting
that open mic I go back up or no I was
next I go back up and I'm just like hey
I just want to say that that's not
indicative of all of us I'm sorry and
but literally the woman had
turn sideways and put her hand up like a
partition yeah in front of her face done
and I get off stage I you know bomb and
then Mike black goes that is the worst
thing I've ever seen anyone do to room
in mind and then why Kyle was dead like
what six months later yeah and more
importantly by that black family yeah I
bet they're in the right eye I collected
the remember we had a UH comment cards
back then yeah I collected the guy
member that comment card that said
something about white kyle is gonna get
raped in jail I hope someone turns it
you into a [ __ ] in jail when you get
raped white [ __ ] thats what i call came
from that's how he was referred to and
then after he died someone put up like a
like a flyer like hey donate for the Ari
Shaffir torrid town is this guy [ __ ]
sucked yeah nobody liked him he was a
piece of [ __ ] we're not doing this
ceiling from Davy Westers yeah
disability funds they live together you
just steal all Davies money yeah he was
a bad guy he was he was so bad that it
was the only phone call I've ever got
from Nick Yousef like my phone rang I
answered I was in Colorado he was like
hey dude it's Nick I'm like what's up
Nick he's like hey white Kyle's dead
it's like that's great he's like yeah I
thought you'd want to know I mean it's
you feel weird being like that guy
sucked but he objected suck yeah no but
it's true they were evil like that they
died then everybody makes a saint like
in a no [ __ ] not that quick yeah I
gotta say Harris Pete was an [ __ ] he
threw a woman down the steps okay that
was hilarious I also i also saw james
also through a woman down the steps
harris p also saw there's a lady
squatted out in the front patio started
pissing he just grabbed her by the hair
and threw in the sunset with the stream
of piss following i remember to risen
there was a woman in the main room once
especially when the stream doesn't who
was not even in a rapid wasted on her
birthday got up on stage and Freddie
Lockhart was on stage like showed her
ass and then went into the driveway and
pissed on the floor yeah and I remember
I was on stage in the o.r while it was
happening and I just remember being like
that that girl has a dad
everyone stood up to watch her pee in
the driveway why I mean that's the kind
of class we provide here at the world
famous how it was back then yeah it was
a weird I'd be lying if I said I don't
miss it a little yeah they're fun times
yeah and distilled the total like no
pressure no what you could do whatever
you wanted no nobody was running the
asylum no we unless there is a night
where we drew names and did each other's
acts which by the way none of us were
famous so the notion that the crowd
would understand what was going on I
like they did that a lot like even when
way back there was a group called the
fun bunch that used to do that I got
plated painters are different than scum
bunch yes a fun bunch the fun bunch
included people like Nancy pimento
though I work they don't sound nearly as
fun man no they weren't I think Don just
made that that oh yeah Arlo's stone
Arliss and they I mean they were really
cool I mean Nancy right shameless Nancy
is a terrific writer oh cool ah but she
was a paid regular she was one of the
only ones that got passed as a paid
regular I her game but they used to go
up and do each other's act and I'd be
waiting tables go no one really gives a
[ __ ] yeah I mean no one knows you guys
ain't it I did better it as painter than
as I then I was doing as myself I think
that easy and I remember active the
first time Joe Rogan ever spoke to me he
was like that impression was beautiful
he was like you could tell you really
worked on it like I really tried David
Taylor got me and I had so little of an
act all he knew to do was like shake
like like jake would nerves and for some
reason i was chi used to call the crowd
party people all the time be like what's
up party oh yeah that's not in the best
light show you the best height man in
the visual i wus y'all what a part of a
bad comedian cubes and party people who
are not sucked man word long do you feel
like I mean aside from me telling you
you're getting better how long did it
take you to get to get okay yeah to
where you were to at least we were like
I'm not terrible at this i'd say at
least six or seven years yeah it took me
a long time to work like but that's
normal yeah i mean to feel like I can
either fix a bomb that was happening
whereas before that it was like once I
started bombing of like well this is all
this happening like I literally do not
have any any tools to fix it bro yeah I
was like oh well another one like it was
like I just accepted it it took about
six years for me to be like okay I know
what to do now i have just it's just
it's just joke density but you always a
working actor yeah and so you had that
like I know but it was just that's not
gonna help you at the world famous guy
that's true but I'm thankful comedy I
had to kind of overcome it for a little
while yeah because people were calling I
don't the [ __ ] [ __ ] this act yeah a
little bit like [ __ ] this more people
dicks to you and not like dicks but you
could tell it was just kind of like how
long's this guy going to stay here like
he already has a show he's probably
milking yes like I'll just do like mix
this guy cuz you have to remember the
kind of poor everyone was fact that I
was gonna say like you didn't have that
others know I wasn't poor that's think I
could like come here in park at the
hotel or like park at pinked out like I
don't have my license your stress yeah I
could just come to the open mic it was I
didn't have a day job like it was just
way easier on me and so as a people got
a sense of that they're just you know
seeming a commercial whatever there was
a little like let's see if you're if you
can hang and become a part of this like
incredibly dark family yeah you know and
eventually I just kind of accepted me
you were the Maryland of the monster
yeah exactly a little bit yeah I mean I
didn't do drugs yeah I didn't like get
wasted I didn't hang out super-late at a
girlfriend right like so it took a while
it took a while to fit into the kind of
I did lawyer we were like human and were
like yeah I was for a while I used I was
what known is just like the most
well-adjusted one I did a I did the Holy
with Freddie Lockhart and Kevin one time
and we all got together to drive down
there and we were like we're going to be
smoked Apollo on the way down there he
was like I mean can't you just wait till
you get there and we're like no no we're
gonna be smoking the way down and dad is
like all right I'm taking a different
car yeah I can't get high in a car so he
drove down separately a nice move inland
we have a problem in
baby but he's like now we're good I feel
like may we have a problem we couldn't
make it the two hours was only hazed
Adam apathy yeah it's a nap and steen
felt the wrath of the biggest bully at
The Comedy Store I just decided you
would have no reason to believe in the
blueberry bit Wow and we just like may
Depp enstein do things for no reason
like we made one night we were like you
can't say a word we're all gonna be
working for that guy yeah seriously
we're like you can't say a word for 20
seconds when you get up there to get up
there and then we also it was like fine
oh and as soon as you got the condo we
like I threw his suitcase on the deck
like you sleep here now oh my picked up
his bag and just throw it out there and
then we're being Freddie you're sitting
there hi just like holy [ __ ] Kevin's
gone off the deep end I never seen just
looked at affect the [ __ ] is wrong yeah
but then I brought it back any broad
like I just kick and then but then we
made him use Jimmy pits catchphrase
where the weed at yeah we're like you
have to say it four times during your
site and he had to open with it yeah we
just made it he was like doing ten
minutes so for use in 10 minutes four
times less than that it could have been
seven he was still new enough to it that
it really affected it would [ __ ]
everything up yeah yeah and he had that
nervous tic then it just after every
joke he did he just stupid so that was
like a fitness set was just angrily
saying stupid pumping where the weed at
where the weed at and he had to open
with it he went up on stage evanston
just the nicest man is so nice like just
a reasonable person yes it was like
where to where the where's the weed at
yeah yeah and la jolla they were like
[ __ ] yeah so like he doesn't have jokes
to follow up that that is ha jokes yeah
yeah it was good times what it so when
the Nerds turn boli that's when the fun
begin where he just called you a nerd
that's fine all right
he identified no not for the 35 million
time this dude [ __ ] in high school we
kill ya no I didn't never I didn't [ __ ]
till I was 22 really yeah I was pretty
afraid of sex I thought I was gonna
knock section girls Oh sex so no really
yes the action yeah afraid of knocking
somebody up and I was horrified of it I
was I pretended I was really into Jesus
in high school had about my head just so
you know I must hurt myself stupid
Catholic section of epson I went as I
went to jesus camp and stuff all right
yeah yeah that's sweet it's so I didn't
know cubes depicted p h christ and they
never teach you to pull out and Jesus
Calvin so we're like they just help
there's so much more eye contact when
you're doing it for Christ do you
believe in oceania do you know I don't
that's just sweet thing that high school
like a high the kitchen ciana t is the
bullet gave me an easy excuse to not be
[ __ ] right I could get an not drink
cuz I was afraid of that too so I could
just be afraid of I would somebody
pregnant if you got to know I just
didn't know how to drink in and in my
high school was like kind of a football
high school so drinking to me just met
like every time there was he'd go to
like if I went to high school party
which is pretty rare it would just let
in a brawl and I was like imma fight
those guys are huge so I just didn't
drink I just didn't like it I'm not good
i mean they're not grow up at la
crescenta or Yousef crew yeah I just not
that I asked my dad when I was 25 I was
like I don't like fun he was like yeah I
don't I don't like it either like it's
just how we are I was like oh like
honest about it like I never liked it
was it is your dad the one that didn't
like music yeah that's ogre my mom told
me after they got divorced he said she
found a note he'd written to himself at
like 30 that said like learn to enjoy
music okay you gotta remind yourself
yeah like you know I should try this
music thing people seem to like
universally to the others never yeah
okay there was never like music in the
car playing or like he just I don't know
he's
just a really straight laced dude that's
awesome though I can't play music but he
also smoked with the windows up and
there was ten of us and look that's a
follow that careful he's a good guy at
least the songs were on were like we
can't breathe differently like shot a
gun at you to scare you in the
typewriter story yes he shot me a few
times but once was with the the rifle
and the other time was a 45 the I saw
the fire like he was that close to my
East Coast is such a different that's
the one terrible just put him in the
East Coast I'm gonna put in just like
special wing grace or valuation Lee but
you get more of that there cuz just
weather makes you different yeah when
you don't have whether you don't spend
as much time indoors you don't have as
much an opportunity to be as weird like
it's just can't I sure does tougher life
like things are more difficult I think
it just creates different personalities
yeah he also liked my neighbor was
having trouble or his neighbor was
having trouble with their kid kids crazy
he used to like just pull up our skirts
every time like I be this punch in this
mucocele here the comedy store four
nights a week oh no now he's a cop and
Philadelphia anyway everybody's fine
yeah everybody that's who you are yes my
dad went to scare him and he was
pointing a gun at him yeah meanwhile
both the kids parents were in prison so
it's like he had nothing I'm een really
it's an act out a my dad and he's scared
him with the gun and it went off and
ricochet two went through his hand Jesus
Christ I was like dad did I still talk
to you even after you hey he earned that
bullet oh yeah I knew you guys were
after that when I first met the kings of
leon years and years ago they just got a
record deal they were like children like
the bass player was 17 and they're like
yeah man our uncle shot our other uncle
because he was sleeping with his wife so
that uncle he didn't die went over hit
him in the head with the [ __ ] pickaxe
he didn't die they just call the
tradesmen like that's incredibly fair
hey that and authentic that's all
american yeah that's some real [ __ ] like
you know what you both had your chance
you usually go now you chose a pickaxe
you both failed yeah fair's fair
don't die you both win yeah I think I
think I respect the pickaxe more yeah I
mean anyone could shoot on you like get
some unknown okay I got a life you get
good leverage on it like the really
thick axe is heavy and I don't aim it
improperly I'll kill him hmm you gotta
get good leverage yeah unless you knock
them down then just go to work but that
is that's multiple hits yeah yeah yeah
it's all about one hit like this is like
a knock on the door door opens pick axe
attack I think I hey after hearing what
you just said the key is you pick axe
the knee and once they get to the ground
that's when you take them well then you
can just take that angle and go to work
well that's true all the pickaxe handle
you could kill a guy in 10 10 smashes
have a lot of pickaxe in South Philly so
no that's why we use the gun right yeah
look I feel like South Philly just fall
asleep to gunfire softs like that scene
in big he's in that hotel he hears the
gunshots outside well do you remember
when that guy you were still a waitress
here okay and some kid showed up from
like South Philly ok because Simone and
would like recognize his accent
immediately was like I can tell like he
had the hair and everything and he went
up on stage and dropped an N bomb like
like it was any word in the English
hello yeah like any word in the English
language I was hosting was it a friend
of mine no I think but you and I think I
was Simone noticing more like oh my God
look at this kid yeah and his joke was
like la sucks I'm trying to run a
charity scam with the supermarket and
people are looking at me like I'm and
then drops the n-word and that is and i
justwell range oh yeah keeps going like
it's nothing and we're all just like ha
like it was swear it wasn't 2016 but was
2006 yeah i was like huh and i'm hosting
and i get back on stage ago doc look at
he droppin in bamako married director
like it was hot and it was just and the
kid I remember he said I'm gonna give it
six weeks and if I don't make it I'm
going back really what six six times six
weeks if you can't do in six weeks and
ignite one other spot he was horrendous
I believe that because they have a
certain
howdy that they're so great and they're
really not I mean I love my people I do
but there are some classic acts i think
i think when i was talking to Yakov he
was here the similar planner is like I
come to LA if I'm not famous in a week
and a half it's not going to happen yeah
that works for him yeah and the only
thing that worked out for him was that
Mitty was here the night that he had to
do some showcase for NBC or CBS or
something but she was probably casting
it to back then and maybe she was the
cast for NBC I just know he said that he
came in and he had to spot at the improv
and then came over he had a spot here
bombed at the improv came over here the
people didn't show up for the show at
the improv came over here bombed people
didn't show up for the showcase here
either until he just left like oh well
at least no one saw it and then it to
you all you gotta stay I like the way
you ball that was the best part about
when I got here if you got on the
showcase list mitzi wouldn't show up for
months yeah do you have that she got two
spots you got a spot Sunday because
you're on the showcase list they gave
you a spot to like practice yeah so I
was in the showcase list for no [ __ ] six
months and she never showed up so I got
three minutes every Sunday money without
even having to like have re gimme a spot
so she eventually August she eventually
showed up and I didn't get past the
first time I showcase cuz I ate it do
you remember your material was it it was
had a lot of stuff about like
transvestites reception I don't actually
remember what that I don't remember that
what that stuff would have been back
then but like and then the second time I
showcased it was during Christmas so
there was like eight people in the
showcase listen only four of us showed
cuz people went out of town and she
randomly showed up and I did like kind
of the best out of the four and I only
did like kind of okay and then Duncan
call me was like she did it she passed
you and then banned me like what like a
like six months later she saw me and
just was like he stinks and told Tommy
to get rid of me Tommy didn't and I hid
from her for like a year yeah so I never
let her see me and then
I was already on stage and she came in
and watched me and I was like doing well
and she said Tommy like I thought I told
you to get rid of him and tell me is
like wow everybody likes him and she was
like when I guess that counts for
something I didn't I got to say I do we
do that a lot like there was a comic
that she loved that had a guitar mm-hmm
and one night he was on without the
guitar in the or and I just saw her pull
in name names no I saw her please Tommy
is Brian she'll know I saw the car
coming I was like oh [ __ ] she's gonna
flip you know and because there was a
few comics that had things they had yeah
have fun yeah and so I didn't like
Dooley not doing is yeah Jackie banana
had to wear the banana coat like it was
awful yeah it was like I hate this
[ __ ] in all fairness Jen Anna she
named him that that wasn't his name oh
god oh my DJ pubes didn't [ __ ] she's
American yeah she would make you do DJ
pubes clearly yeah that would be it you
would have to have pubes all over you
there have been so famous I want to just
got to my guns that would not have
worked 100 not a virgin but yeah she
walked in i couldn't distract her yeah
and she looked and she saw as she did a
double take i was like [ __ ] and she's
like jesus christ and she went up the
steps i never saw her move that fast
yeah I'm the light get him out of here
no I was like see I never I never
incurred her wrath past being banned at
one time and after that she just forgot
who I was but you did get banned cuz you
didn't have the you know no she was
decided I sucked yeah which fair enough
I mean but she did that a lot to people
though yeah it would be like I don't
know what I was thinking she did what
Jimmy and Joe it was beautiful yeah
that's one of those things react finally
fine I'm ever getting actually like this
means so much then like four months
later Jimmy and Joey got past and like
it doesn't really mean yeah everyone i
know i got past and someone got passed
right out to me I was like oh it's
absolutely meaningless yeah we're just
like that person objectively horrible no
wonder I don't know any of the names on
the wall she just passed his garbage
yeah but you pass them and then cheeping
like aw [ __ ] i [ __ ] up well that's
what some I forget it was someone who
around during the 80s was like oh it
wasn't hard to get past here back then
in the eighties and out the other day
because it was like a the place was
packed out the show's ran for hours yet
you know westwood like you could get she
had the other yeah at vegas yeah west
which she had lovely a lot of comics so
it wasn't like the mountain it would
that it that people make it out to be
there was so many comedy stores going at
one point that Allen Steve until we
interviewed last week kept saying stuff
about in people said I was going to buy
sunset and stuff and and for a good five
minutes I'm like I see mean he's getting
by sunset in like all that that's how he
refers to this place yeah because there
are so many comedy stores that this was
just known a sunset sunset because I
whole strip [ __ ] yeah I wish man the
westwood thing sounds cool yes we are
great that's what that when you hear
about that like that sounded like a
[ __ ] that was is hearty yeah all
college kids that would have been like
that was like alternative comedy before
like if that would have stuck but not
alternative cuz you got kinnison's you
got that they were kidding savoring I
don't care what anyone who's [ __ ]
geeks want to say Kinnison is
alternative we was alternative comedy
for that time so [ __ ] different doing
set like that guy wasn't doing anything
that anyone else was doing yeah but I
get maybe I have a different idea of
what alternative comedy I just think
it's anything I'm sorry's without
punchlines well yeah no I just think of
it as do I wrong no cuz forever I'll
turn most alternative comics comics are
just one liners that's why they get on
late-night a lock cities I always
thought I was doing a podcast with Moshe
kasher and I said something about yeah
then you get all these [ __ ] fruitcake
alternative comics and he's like what
does that mean I'm like you know
alternative County like where you just
try and be clever and not funny he's
like that it's not alterna comedy is
something I could be wrong I really
don't always this alternative comedy is
the same dirty joke with a where you add
a thesaurus so do we all have a
different opinion on it well I think
genuine alternative comedy is someone
who's just doing something that's not
like anyone else and I think Candace is
all the time
falls into that innocent comes right now
is he an alternative comic well be no
because you have all the people that
followed in his wake but do it like he
did yeah yet Bobcat you had people that
realize it like the pure aggression is
is like a means to it like you can you
can affect the crowd in that way where
you put them off then you bring them
back and you put them off and yeah you
scare the [ __ ] out of them then it's
it's what you see Holtzman so brilliant
interesting what you're saying yeah well
minutes when he put loads and then
brings you back when he explodes and
then the quiet it's just like you're
like god you're a [ __ ] it's like
mania it's like a pixie song we might
we're like dude you're [ __ ] this is
crazy yeah we're gonna die wait you're
not gonna kill us it's the classic like
it's beautiful up that makes perfect
sense my favorite story is that after
nine eleven Mitzi wouldn't let Holtzman
come in for like a week she was like she
was terrified and went and took but as
soon as he showed up his opening bit was
we're gonna get a pen we're gonna get a
flatbed truck and if you're not black or
white get in the pen and he just starts
to keep screaming just yelling different
ethnicities get in the [ __ ] pen oh if
there's any said I wish I could have
seen it would have yeah that was my
favorite like he loved America when it
was just black and white he always used
to say that nice to scream my head off
like yeah remember when it was just
black and white man after um basically
means he when he didn't live in Southern
California yeah was it Columbine or one
of them he was making fun of maybe
Oklahoma those kids that were in the
bill that they were like there were
kindergarten kids in their little kids
it was like 94 or something like that
and it was a little bit after that he
just brought it back up and compared it
to something else and he's like those
kids they weren't good kids they were
drinking the chemicals under the sinker
and I was like that's the thing the
audience this guy is forty percent of
his act you'd go I mean that guy you
want to talk I I think about like the
comics who maybe they weren't famous but
had like have left a mark on this place
that guy left a mark on this place that
will never go away and I think yeah
holds from their comics that don't know
their descendants of Holtzman save it
Brody yeah well I thought I saw Holtzman
maybe like two months ago so it was
sometime over the summer so maybe a
little bit longer but he you remember
that night he was ranting about uh how
Tommy is running the puppet strings of
Adam oh yeah what do you think Ricky
girls getting spot every night is good
this starts yelling I'll just hit the
back of what the crowd has no idea who I
am I didn't go up in that show it's okay
all the comics at the back laughing and
then I look over and there's just this
large black lady and she just does the
turn like just not sure what's going on
so just turns looking towards the door
just not even face yeah it's like ain't
about this no angry white people but
yeah he he he to me is emblematic at
that time where it's like no that place
is different yeah that's why I stayed
here and didn't go like I I mean when I
first started I was friends with a lot
of the kind of like all people and I
went up in some of those rooms and like
I just stayed here cuz i was like that
place is weird yeah and it attracted to
them and I was like there's plenty of me
over there yeah there were there were
just plenty of like skinny acerbic
glasses-wearing dude those like they
don't need any of me over there and
there was like only one or two of me
over here and I was also like that place
is weird and I [ __ ] like that place I
just slide this is the first place I
ever went to in my entire life where I
felt like a normal person yeah like
growing up was always the weird kid
that's always bizarre some people
thought was funny some people just
thought I was weird but I always felt
out of place when I came here as I mean
these people are [ __ ] up man I'm I'm
normally I always I mean I always was
like hurting my friend's feelings by
like we'd be sayin stuff and I'd always
be the one that got like a two V yeah
and I didn't even anyways kept it too
real exactly yep the two pubes
yeah I was like any of my head I'd be
like what like I didn't I actually
wasn't I didn't get why you and everyone
got bummed and then I came here I was
like oh this is my home this is the best
these people are well I was we were
talking about the other day that one
time you and me went up to the ding dong
show and just objectively decided to
scream and Sam the Armenian comedians
for no reason amazing and like I don't
mean scream I mean like bloody murder
top of our lungs just screaming shut the
[ __ ] up Sam [ __ ] you you're a worthless
piece of [ __ ] like for no reason when in
Turkey finish the job yeah it's like I
mean we were just [ __ ] awful reminder
that part in fight club when he when he
[ __ ] kick Brad Pitt beats the [ __ ]
out of jail is I don't want to destroy
something beautiful yeah and it's just
like we just decided that night to be
horrible to someone who sucks but still
don't you did nothing to us yeah and I
was saying that the Duncan and Duncan
just goes both there's blood on all our
hands tell me like scare and I was like
oh dude you're right like back then yeah
it was a it was mad whatever you want to
say about this place back then you could
say like oh it was sexist and racist
you'd be like yes it was yeah and I
probably played a part in it at one
point yeah like there's blood on if you
were here between nineteen what 95 and
2010 when it was just a no man's land
and no one was here my whole life yeah I
mean there's blood on all our hands it's
so sad I used to ruin Josh Nasar sets
every Friday yeah this is Josh Nasar
roast do my set right now he just had to
like executive after what is easy hey
Argus are you here for the Josh Nasar
Rose is it tough just like anyone just
wanted to [ __ ] with him we just decide
to do a thing and there was no one know
what I stopped you dude the best is when
we used to play football in the foosball
oh yeah regulars oh yeah the football
team with the wall we were setting up
glassware on the ledge to try to knock
it off with the football yeah yeah just
breaking lush and polly was parking lot
yeah Paulie was like did you can't do
this and we were like well why
shut up what do you mean way to tell
your mom she's the piles of broken glass
everywhere what do you being such a
[ __ ] [ __ ] for what do we need glass
for yeah it was just like what are you
serving drinks us for people here we're
breaking glass man like it was it was
such a hurry I remember this girl pulled
up one night standing out front me and
she's ER and John is like hey that looks
like so into a some girl that we knew
from college she rolled down her window
and she was like hey John and he's like
holy [ __ ] it's her no went over we're
start talking this girl for like five
inches like oh [ __ ] you live out here I
can't believe it's so crazy to see you
and she's like I drove by and I saw you
guys and I was like I think that was
them you guys used to have those parties
and all the less I'm like yeah cool you
should come in and hang out she's like
no I came here one time and this tall
bald guy made me cry and I've never come
yeah that's all good those can see you
right but that's not gonna stop so I'll
probably never see you again but
Taylor's made everyone cry here at some
point at some point he has made but I
will tell you what he won't do what mess
with a perv I oh really I never knew
that cuz he had a friend that was a
schizophrenic okay and again David
nothing but we're me my entire life
which is hysterical i just me my dog
like you know i love he busted my balls
a little bit beginning but that was it
like once you find out that you're not
[ __ ] it was one of the ones that was
that told you like you got those
impressions are not you guys stop doing
that that was all my first memories of
you to yes standing in the conversation
just nodding your head like dude you're
funny if you keep doing with this will
ferrell [ __ ] yes we do a thorough a
woman no one sees you and thinks
anything but will ferrell yeah so stop
this yeah that's funny I didn't know you
guys would do that to one another like
stop doing those no I we already did to
Ric yeah that was only Lisa oleta / did
it to you and David told me he didn't
tell me to stop doing something just
goes a lot of dick jokes too right
that's why I think that's helping yeah
one of my first bits was like sis's
awful joke about like wouldn't be great
if you could borrow other dudes dicks
when you needed a bigger one I'm liking
it was so [ __ ] garbage and it was
like holding everyone
rush out and get a black friend and
their feelings would be like you only
call me when you want this dick and I be
like now let's go now tomorrow we'll go
do some will go see lilo and stitch yes
and and I sequitur referencing
everything badly and then I can I go
guys know what people of animated films
and for some reason that would either
get a giant laugh or a like intense moan
and I was like I don't even know what it
means i don't know what i mean by what I
say it I don't even know that it's
racers conviction there every race loves
animated films right like I don't know
if you'll be like oh hey like I don't
know why you're offended cuz I don't
know what I'd is that a Babe a kid's
joke [ __ ] love baby the any baby kiss
baby when the kid turns on goes damn
crack baby baby baby it's kid some of
the greatest things ever it was pretty
awesome yeah so but David Oh before its
time it was actually eres I really was
Bebe's kids would be a series now yeah
still be on ya would be a long-running
series yeah yeah release the cleveland
show wait who made babies kids Robin
Harris Robin Harris yeah he was good he
was amazing or Paulie took credit for
getting him on stage here that was funny
like I pulled him out of the black shows
you don't need to be over here come over
here like polish is all I could do with
these people come yeah yeah oh you know
you're one of the good ones come with me
like oh she's weird call the interview
is the bet did Ian Edwards has ten he's
like dude how cool are black people
right it's like sounds pretty racist you
say a polygon we had him on my podcast
and I I will kill it Ian Polly and I way
to like the very and I was like hey did
you ever like skateboard back and he
goes dude I was sponsored I was like how
am I just why wouldn't why didn't we
talk about this whole time yeah he's
like well because I'm making it up right
now it's a bold faced tonight he's like
Dean Gail remember Dean gal were claims
former comedy store manager claimed that
he was part of the dogtown z-boys yeah
well it well like really he's like dude
I had to flow in hair back there and
we're like I mean you did tricks all I
just like do my thing was going down the
hill really fast we're like I'm pretty
sure that's not
thing worthy of being and then we had
bugzilla I used to used to drive the
actual dogtown z-boys around because he
had a he was old enough to drive back
then and we're like muxes you remember
Dean he's like Dean then hang with the
guys oh I love that we're going to my
way two mugs illin know the dogtown
z-boys guys yeah he literally was like
three years older than him but had a car
and was old enough to drive so he was
the one who driving around all their
events and oh wow it like that serious
is is modular dude I was the Dogtown jar
just arrived so he like basically was
skip England's right-hand man kind of
yeah that's the guy who ran the team oh
yeah ah that's [ __ ] fast I like that
you know that yeah I mean I know I know
everything about skateboarding are you a
big skateboard guy I mean yeah yeah what
state board yourself not anymore I'm too
old I I was never too old every once a
while I get really angry and about some
skateboarder doing something that's
bothering me and I'm get ready to tweet
some sort of skateboarder hate my mind I
go yeah I might offend Kevin right i
mean like anyone was a skateboard should
die there's not the best that we don't
respect stuff our producer probably came
here on a skateboard tonight yeah I mean
yeah we don't like what a loser you
don't get boy we don't care about stuff
Ramona and I respect i say we i just
wanna BES Gators like like you look at
like a brand-new building that someone
just finished and you see like a marble
like a marble incline you're like let's
[ __ ] ruin it yeah like you know in
some poor security guards gotta chase
you around someone making minimum wage
oh yeah with a some pepper spray yeah
and you make this like overweight dude
chase you because you're just because
you want to skate boards you're badass
dude and yeah you will ero everywhere
literally later I scape where we used to
skateboard in vet stadium cuz huh yeah
and then they catch us and throw us in
that jail son of a [ __ ] well now
girls are so much better scaper never
been it's actually one of the cooler
parts of skateboarding I think cuz girls
are good at it there sooner better than
they're great at it and like they can
actually kind of make a little money but
they're not they haven't been like
ruined yet
it by the court is a corporate element
skateboarding is ruining parts of it got
it and they're not white that's a
genuine skateboarder of you to say
although last week of very famous and
where Paul Rodriguez was here Paul
Rodriguez is there is all son son well
great street skaters of all time
parasites out there like nightmares on
shoot he's like he's got a lot of it
he's got a lot of like he is well that's
good for Paul yeah he had a you know yes
I love I know Paul I don't know a son
right I tried skiing elderly people not
the younger than I tried skateboarding
very unsuccessfully for like a solid
month and I was like you know what I'm
just gonna I'm just gonna mock these
people it's so instead of getting good I
was never good my balance was just never
so [ __ ] hard I i I'd like probably a
solid 15 heart falls on my elbows I'm
like this is gonna ruin my athletic
career yeah don't stop they were gonna
say your stand up an area pro ball
player right I really just want like
around all I want to do is draw the
graphic that's all I cared about you
still do that stuff though right yeah
like design skateboards I do a
skateboard graphics skateboard graphic
you do like the long boards with the big
I don't do long board since you're
you're legit dude words longboard I
could ride a longboard all you know what
though recently there's these guys that
like high-speed longboard we're even me
is like at longboards later like whoa
you're going genuinely fast my friend
like we're likely over da he'll fight
similar Dean Gilbert I believe he's got
top speed yeah the record but like guys
are following them in car is doing like
60 and you're like if you fall you're a
hamburger so you can't hate on it you're
like all right man i would i would do
that hold onto the back of my friend
Edward Barrios got dragged our team Adam
lifestyle yeah I was quite the hood rat
yeah I when I lived in i lived in
colorado after the summer of my freshman
year at college and there's just like me
and my friend and a bunch of like hippie
dudes and like loser Christian kids
because we were staying at a Christian
so it's
we hung out would be cool loser kids and
bunch of them had long boards I just
remember that the escape border kids I
knew thought the longboarder guys were
[ __ ] [ __ ] you can't do tricks so
I'm just yes I kept saying I literally
can't do a [ __ ] trick on it so you're
just like you just crazy ow yeah come on
man yeah that was a Freddy so when I see
a longboarder I'm just like oh you got a
DUI okay and that what happened all our
people these dudes that they're thing
was they would go at nights when there's
a full moon in Colorado it just lights
everything up because there's no
artificial light I guess so they would
all go have someone take them up to the
top like trail ridge road which is like
you know 13,000 feet high and then they
would basically hide until they closed
rocky mountain national park then they
cruise down all the way should take them
like an hour that's cool hour and a half
of just like rollin yeah and I might do
it hell no I didn't do just a summary no
i said yes nobody would know just put on
my solo phone some Dave Matthews Band
and [ __ ] cruise that yeah thank God
I'm not listening to dave matthews
unless i'm making out with chicks in 97
think of the amount of herpes cause
right after it Dave Matthews concert in
Colorado had to be oh I'm gonna be
honest i don't think i know one song
good is that awful they're hard to know
cuz they're all over the place is a lot
of like it's it's kind of proggy so it's
just kind of this like instrumental like
bill burr talks about use the leaders
for family who's the leader of receding
hairline rock for a while he handed it
off to get gray and then went into
oblivion I don't know what he looks like
either he's kind of a balding weird look
he does--like a daughter but if eric b
and rakim came you know that [ __ ] quick
my friend John Bronson and I know I
don't know how but he somehow knew rock
am really and get back yes oh where does
that one of the greatest I actually
tried to get my friend cuz that rock him
has like the best voice ever at hip hop
and my friend had this like electronic
record label I was like why don't you
call rock him and give him like 10 grand
and be like just say all the names of
the groups on my label it'll take you 10
min
it's just saying with your voice and
then everyone can use them in their
music yeah like at the beginning out
he's like that's a great idea in it like
it like at him to say DJ pubes yes a JPG
pubes like whatever the sweet rocking
voice but my friend I don't know how my
friend knew him but his girl there at a
Laker game him is him in and now wife
but this is years ago they were just
dating and they show Rakim on the
jumbotron Laker game eagles that's my
friend she's like you're lying idiot
like this is the whitest guy ever she's
like don't lie to me I'm I already like
you yeah like whatever you know he goes
walks over and like missing is like you
know fist hugging rock him and
apparently i don't know how i became
friends but they would take my friend
John to clubs with him to black clubs
like hip-hop clubs and they the way they
kept her from getting beat up as they
say he's one of the new kids on the
block oh my god and no one knew what
they actually look like they're like I
look he was a young white get fine I
God's when the new kids on the floor all
on the block one of my favorite new kids
stories as I was working up a shipping
department a post-production house like
10 years ago and my boss the shipping
department manager was Richie Taylor
manager of the comedy store I wonder
then I remember how that was the job you
one of the jobs you could get from
Richie yeah do we get the waiter job
yeah or that job yeah that's a waiter
the delivering towels job or what like a
restaurant that he could get yeah comedy
straight a friend yes they had a friend
of a haircut comedians so it was me and
Richie and for black dudes and that was
the shipping department and we'd sit
around just talk [ __ ] all day was
[ __ ] fun yeah easy job whatever and
uh one day Richie starts telling a story
about how he and his boys used to just
get all sorts of [ __ ] back and in
Cleveland back then when they're like a
high school or whatever he's like all we
got so much [ __ ] in the black Tuesday
days David Len lemons and he's like he's
like yeah like you know you just
spitting game I mean what's going on is
like oh we just dressed like the new
kids on the block and we just got the
pusses the one who goes you did what
yeah we trust like the new kid she's
like and I got you pull
I was like it's the best you can get
beat up yeah wait back up because [ __ ]
is going on in Cleveland Thank You
Cleveland with shitty I knew it the
belly diet anything to pick on Richie
yeah and it just made me picture Richie
at all times and a Letterman's jacket of
some sort one of those leather sleeves
eight-ball jacket yeah the leather one
ya know a true yeah some some dope as
[ __ ] it's one of them pubes jacket got
me a Carl can I don't even know what
time is it was like a hip-hop label like
flew before FUBU but it was kind of like
high class yeah I got Carl can I boots
for homecoming mom golly I went to
homecoming and I didn't want to buy
dress shoes so I was like I'll never
wear these again check out Carl can I
boots from the Pasadena mall they were
all hundred dollars and I was just like
this is the best [ __ ] ever this is where
I don't relate to people when they go to
public school I don't understand it you
know I've never had a no dances I was
the worst you had have so many outfits
not to feel like you were poor yeah I
mean I just I just accepted I was poor I
guess I went to ross that's worried
about clothes we had that JC Penney's
y'all yeah former Catholic school yeah i
think i think the entire the you country
should wear uniforms at school yeah cuz
then you don't have you don't you can't
pick up poor kids don't don't feel
different you need one outfit a week it
would he give you free dress on friday i
went to last every dance that the girl
is a lesbian now so I'm feeling pretty
good about my [ __ ] I had my first the
fur I've had my first [ __ ] former
probably the wrong way recently had the
first girl I hung out with is marrying a
woman as my first lesbian yeah I went to
the first turn i was miss girls lesbian
wedding last I guess it would've been
last May in Florida there was a lesbian
wedding on the beach was [ __ ]
beautiful right we're sitting down there
it's like pretty much is near like
destined so it's basically like that
redneck Riviera part or a florida
southern alabama more or less yeah so
we're all sitting down on the beach
waiting for this wedding to start and I
see these rednecks what start walking
over like I there's a wind let's go
watch I turned to Crane oh my just just
watch these guys faces while I just wait
when when he sees that it's two women
just watch two dudes one other chick and
then a kid and so the first bride comes
down there just kind of standing there
watching and then the second remarkably
short yeah wait a sec she looks like
she's good at collegiate soccer huh it
reminds me of that one because it the
second ride starts walking down the one
guys like you see me like get your [ __ ]
we're at it I love the like we have to
get out of here like they're gonna get
you yeah like this could happen my kid's
gonna catch lesbea we shake her hand she
I don't know if you know this as my dad
calls some girl [ __ ] she's pretty
awful but that's how he says it that's a
legit I turned my first great band name
I told him I was a flower girl in a
lesbian wedding for tami jo upstairs
that's that she came in yeah it looks as
the closer show well I'll run out there
in a second right uh that's just how I
do I make him wait what did your dad say
that's when he freaked out he was like
the girl [ __ ] and I was like that
they're lesbians I was like I don't care
where they're from that's not a plan
it's a wonderful answer there's a
concert level I love that page I love
that a bit like I'm not learning
anything new no I'm not okay I'm not the
town's can change all they won't like
you look I can say whatever the [ __ ] you
want I'm not doing it yeah I'm on a
fixed income [ __ ] you I mean know same
[ __ ] I'm doing the same day does have a
sugar mama so he's a little bit
she gets a little bit in his head like
you can't talk like that and he's like
you know angels hanging out with the you
know she's got those uh those queers
over there she ain't no way but I'm like
dad like your surrounding and he was but
he was searching for the right word he
came up with queer that was a dead
Assange fact that's what my grandmother
called them my grandmother had a stroke
and post-stroke it made it so she could
only taste Chinese food and she became
shockingly homophobic Wow she hated
Louie Anderson she thought he ruined the
feud yeah she was likely really tell
he's a queer no like Grandma like by the
way before this no [ __ ] maybe the nicest
woman I've ever known in my life yeah
but she faced row she was one of those
like post-stroke she was like they took
the rainbow I was like whoa chief I can
only only tastes hot mustard so it was
very strange my grandpa referred to them
as he would just say his kids a little
silly ray and give the eyebrows up yeah
head down look that's a funny kid you
know what I mean funny he's a funny one
I used to hear light in the loafers a
lot like the loafers was a big one but
my dad always says the F word obviously
and just doesn't said it four times now
sorry right side is a [ __ ] I do say a
lot too but my dad really like he's it
so bad at my and his wife she has
friends that come over all the time and
so he just she's beating him down to try
and then my nieces and nephews are like
pop up you can't talk like that we're
all people I loved when Trump dropped
the he was trying to make Hillary look
bad by something he's like you know
she's getting donations from people who
are pushing the gays off of buildings
like wait did he just say pushing the
gay they're doing that in Saudi Arabia a
lot of people are saying it he's doing
you're pushin now that's Tammy I'm gonna
go right back all right all right yeah
we're pretty close here we'll wrap it up
we got three more minutes and then we're
at we're at our hour if we just couldn't
come up with so
so like well just maybe do it we'll do a
song from our heyday when we were when
it's like to you so do you like comedy
how's your baby well babies good she had
a shitty good meltdown right before I
left this eve have you had to travel
with her yet no not really that seems
like the big first thing yes I'm take
baby on a plane when I see I was just at
the airport and I saw a woman getting on
a plane with a baby and she just looked
she look she was holding a bomb we're
just like I don't know how this is gonna
go yeah like just so like I have no idea
what I have no idea what's gonna happen
when I mean a change in air pressure
yeah like I get a headache being on a
plane but I know why it's happening and
kids have bad ears in general yeah every
day new they're all new cars I mean the
best the best thing is that we can't
afford to go anywhere so they're
probably shouldn't be an issue anytime
soon but it's uh me everything's just
more difficult trying to go anywhere
like we remodeled our kitchen and it was
like we're gonna be painting for the
next two days and say we gotta [ __ ]
get this kid out of ya [ __ ] resin it's
like we're calling up Corinne's family
friends out in Agoura Hills like we
stayed your place yeah we got to go out
there and then well we can bring our dog
supper you guys have so many cats
there's a bowl of cat food in every room
of the house yes just like such a
debauch room I've used to be so easy I
was just a drug addict yeah it's so much
easier there's so much pressure that's
how I look back on that time was just
easy it was easy and it was hard cuz
there was never anyone here we were all
horrible yeah horrible horrible
comedians and people of it and bad yeah
legitimately bad people it listen if I
think I'm a good person that's not a
good sign for the other people that's
how I you telesis a hey you know what a
pretty good person yeah I was like the
one that like a cat was a decent dude
it's like no not objectively not
compared to the rest of the world I like
not being [ __ ] that's the thing it's
just the rest of the world of the comedy
store yeah first time I hung out with
anywhere from the comedy store I went to
Sandy
ago with our Ian painter in the first
night re came running out of the one of
the rooms in the condo full erection
jerking it yeah I'm sitting next to
painter on a couch I look over I'm like
what the [ __ ] and then he just comes
right on the same right on the table
right in front of Jim painter pays like
oh my god why would you do that like I
said I like what the [ __ ] is going on
what is wrong with these yeah I mean
like a smile on people's car yeah ah it
was just a hard time making frat dudes
look cool because at least they're 20
yeah lasting 30 doing this yes [ __ ]
are yeah the whole thing is amazing that
the people just I don't think anyone
will ever like remember it or believe
like I don't know but I think they will
this is a weird thing like you guys are
talking about Sam the Armenian with
another comedian and I brought my
boyfriend here and I was like you got to
come upstairs and see the ding dong show
he loved Barris you know so I was like
you got to see this and we're sitting
there he goes that guy's name Sam I'm
like yeah he's like that [ __ ] prick
and I go whoa you know Sam the army yeah
and he's like that [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
was a barber in my neighborhood and they
used to [ __ ] torment him because he
would torment them so that [ __ ] I
terrible things to him so I'm like oh
this happens outside to tell at one
point and it might have been because the
time the kevin and i decided to just go
up and [ __ ] torture this guy but don
was really into it he's like hey uh
could you come back yeah sure I never
went back last week I never went back
ever again I was like I can't I can't
turn into that again somebody is that
willing to be like come on back yeah you
guys busy you know I was literally just
like I have nothing to do let's do this
yes I would go back and I'd always torch
room and yell [ __ ] animal man [ __ ]
Armenia yeah and uh you know be me
sometimes O'Neill or Danish or whatever
was those are perfect so one night
Donna's like hey we're filming tonight
Kim all these people are coming would
you come her
Sam we're gonna try and get him to flip
out so we are sitting up in the like the
side section of the belly room of the
balcony if you will the firing range and
yeah and uh Sam start doing his thinks
we start yelling at him and I had a bag
of sunflower seeds I started just
whipping sunflower seeds at them while
we were yelling at him to shut up you a
dog Armenian the grossest dog day is
this yelling and at one point I just
filled my mouth with sunflower seeds
that SAT directly behind him and then
just spit humble hours all over his head
he got so mad as I was doing it as
Darnell that he ran around and look on
Dante's just like Oh too far he ran all
the way around came up with my oh [ __ ]
this dude's gonna kill me and he just
grabbed me by my hair and started trying
to pull my hair out the whole time
screaming the n-word at me you [ __ ]
n-word how dare you do this and Donn's
like the next day dancing well that was
one of the greatest things of all time
and the fact that he legitimately thinks
you're a black eye because we tell them
your black eye is one of the most
special parts of that whole thing out
like I said there's blood on all our
hands all over here place is special
yeah special does mean [ __ ] no we
are we are we are corrupt prison guards
I am Sailor Moon grape I said the Opera
brain the commie stores the Abu Ghraib
of comedy club yeah Shane's little
minion yeah I've done things I'm still
afraid to talk about yeah that's special
you've all done awful things here yeah
picked a wife me too god I met my met
the mother of my child here how
horrifying is that I first ex-fiancee
here yeah at my second for that matter
ex-wife here I'm not a closer I think
with you look at you to come this time
you walk down that Lane I can't do still
hoping I just don't [ __ ] it up yeah out
of my league yeah but he's awesome yeah
um I'm gonna have to come babysit yep
you're in me too can you do you are you
good with kids no oh I am oh that's
right we were talking bout that upset
yeah I'm good like
sometimes but pre rarely that's my
favorite all right now I came back she
just basically looks at ed no matter
what like quick my parents only my
parents know what they doing yeah could
you hold anyway therefore my brother's
kids look at them they're like until
they bring them to my mom they still
bring their kids to my mom like we don't
know what happened here fix this yeah my
Jesus Christ you know I think kids are
meant to be raised by the grandparents
cuz if you think about it
physiologically you can make a kid so
young I think yea i meant to like you
make a kid at like 14 generator off and
become a [ __ ] person when your
parents are the right age actually raise
a child yeah yeah good you're set I'm
gonna go do myself all right yeah we'll
wrap it up here thanks for being on
Kevin thanks for having me appreciate it
and oops yeah do you have things you
want to promote coming up social media
anything come on the show masters of sex
that's right are gonna be on the new 24
about 24 legacy yes on that and that's
it ok my twitter is kevin g christie
same my instruments same
cubes boobs y'all thanks for listening
comic store podcast come to the comedy
store see a show cubes
[Music]
you
I
[Music]